why does this diet sound so
problematically
familiar hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen let me pop in here super quick
folks cuz I'm so excited to be working
with element this is a product that I
was using years ago when I was on my
breastfeeding Sega and it really helped
me recover and I also use it a lot in
the summer when I'm playing tennis in
the Heat and it's always in my bag when
I travel not to mention a lot of my
colleagues who work in Sports Nutrition
swear by element specifically because
it's got a science back electrolyte
ratio of 1,000 mg sodium 200 Mig
potassium and 60 Mig magnesium and it's
got no colors sugars or fillers I've
also found that having my electrolytes
in the morning has had a really big
positive impact on my sleep so even on
days when I'm not sweating a lot I will
usually still have half a packet I love
all things spicy so the mango chili is
always my fave but they've got nine
different flavors including their new
chocolate caramel which is so strangely
addictive right now element is offering
my viewers a free sample pack with any
order so that's eight single serving
packets free with any element order this
is a great way to try eight other
flavors or share element with a salty
friend so get yours at drink element.com
Abby sharp and this deal is only
available through my link so you have to
go to d r i n k l m nt.com
slabby sharp today we're going to be
revisiting a super problematic diet that
I thought we had put to bed like 8 years
ago but here we are another beautiful
fit blonde on social media making a meal
out of a crate of bananas yep we're
talking about the infamous raw till 4
high carb lowfat low protein diet
consisting largely of fruit lettuce and
potatoes if this sounds familiar to you
you are probably an OG aby's kitchen fan
so thank you guys so much for your
loyalty we love that but it's because I
actually got my start here on YouTube
debunking this dangerous raw vegan frore
diet made famous by well another
beautiful fit blonde so there was a time
when I was receiving hundreds of
messages and emails and DMS from young
girls following this diet and suffering
from horrendous outcomes hair loss
raging blood sugars acne severe IBS
flares muscle wasting amenorrhea and a
lot more it is also not lost on me that
this is a very similar protocol to the
one followed by Russian raw vegan
frugivore Zan de art who passed away in
the summer at age 39 allegedly related
to
malnutrition so I don't know this feels
a bit like a passing of the torch to the
next generation of raw vegan frugivores
and of course I have to worry about a
similar fate but we will be talking
calories and restriction eating today so
that's just a little heads up here um
and if you're not already subscribed I
would love if you would and also check
out my free Hunger crushing combo ebook
in the description below but let's get
into some of PA's videos and take a look
at what she recommends eating to prevent
weight gain to lose weight or to get rid
of cellulite news flash there is no diet
specifically to do that what I eat in a
day so I can eat as much as I want and
never have to worry about weight gain
for breakfast I'm having 4 lbs of
watermelon for lunch I'm eating five
Envy app app for a snack I'm having a
cluster of green grapes and for dinner
I've got a fresh crispy Roma salad along
with yellow curry potato soup now this
is dangerous and frankly just an
incorrect assertion it doesn't matter
what kind of diet you want to follow
keto Weight Watchers calorie counting or
raw till four weight loss or weight gain
comes down to calories and if this works
for Paige or for others it's because
you've been able to create a calorie
deficit not because it's super satiating
in fact despite this diet being made up
of only fruit and vegetables it is super
low in hunger crushing compounds now I'm
not 100% sure what's in the soup but I
estimated around 2,000 calories 34 g of
protein 19 G of fat and 54 G of fiber
and sure the fiber is a lot higher than
the national average but it only makes
up about 12% of total carbs not great
when we're not even hitting the bare
minimum protein targets so I would argue
that most people would not feel very
full at all on a diet like this and if
you did it would be because of the sheer
volume or low caloric density of the
foods which she elaborates on here the
average American has about 4 pounds of
food every day I eat over double that I
always start my morning off with half of
a watermelon which comes out to 4 and
1/2 lbs next up is six bananas at 1.3 lb
for dinner I eat this entire bowl of
soup which has 2 lb of potatoes in it I
also have a large salad that weighs
about a half a pound the fact that
eating 8 lbs of food is treated as like
a flex is kind of a red flag to me now
I'm not diagnosing anyone with anything
I'm simply going to speak from my own
experience as a dietician and also
someone who has had a disorder but
bragging about my massive meal portions
was exactly what I used to do to try to
hide my disorder you know I was like
look at all the food I eat there can't
be anything wrong with me look I eat see
I eat a lot and honestly it kind of
worked like people saw me eat a lot so
they were thrown off on any suspicions
that something was wrong but eating
massive amounts of ultra low calorie
foods in an attempt to stretch the Vagas
nerve and like trick my body into
thinking that I was truly nourished was
a clear sign of my Ed you know I just
wanted so badly to feel full like super
full like physically a full full belly
and the only way to do that while not
gaining weight was to eat massive
amounts of lettuce broth and water-rich
fruit obviously there is some Merit to
consuming more high volume Foods when on
a weight loss diet and that doesn't
necessarily mean one has an ed I mean
we've got lots of research to support
that method but I think it's important
to remind ourselves that even if you can
hack your brain into thinking it's full
by filling your gut with a ton of water
and bulk the likelihood of feeling
satisfied is super super slim like I ran
that race and it was very short-lived
you cannot Marathon it out on a hyper
restrictive diet like that without it
completely messing with your head and
this sentiment from Paige on oils also
feels very very familiar the next thing
I stopped eating was oil I was all into
the keto Vibe and the thing is is like
oil is not satiating and satisfying oil
does not fill you up all oil does is
just give you extra calories without
actually giving you any any bulk behind
those calories without actually filling
you up and making you full and satisfied
I was very strong keto so I was like 80%
of my diet was fat my stomach was never
getting filled up it was just a bunch of
high fat foods that I was eating first
of all I generally think it's a red
flake when I see folks yo-yo from one
extreme diet to another like case and
point high fat keto to lowfat raw vegan
like why do we need to make eating so
complicated no but seriously here is my
take on oils and fats while trying to
lose weight fats contain more calories
per gram than protein or carbs but
they're also very slow digesting so they
stabilize our insulin levels and keep
you feeling Fuller for longer now when
wh loss is the goal I do think we want
to get the bulk of our healthy fats from
whole food sources where they are
bundled up with other hunger crushing
compounds so avocado for example is rich
in healthy fats and fiber nuts have
healthy fats protein and fiber salmon
has healthy fats and protein Etc now
oils are just pure fat AKA they are only
one hunger crushing compound but that
doesn't mean they don't contribute to
fullness or satisfaction or that they
cannot fit in a weight loss diet on the
contrary Reese suggest that added oil
does help to reduce appetite and hunger
hormones when added to our meals it also
makes food taste better which is super
important for the satisfaction piece
like I would be so miserable eating dry
lettuce with no dressing you bet I would
be face planning into a family-sized bag
of
chips and on top of the oil rant let's
clear up some science really easy for
your body to convert the fat that you
eat into the fat that you wear so it
takes a lot less energy for the body to
convert dietary fat into fat storage on
the body but it's a lot harder and takes
more energy to convert carbohydrates
into fat storage which makes sense
because fat is already fat so it's easy
to convert dietary fat into fat storage
because it's already fat that is not how
weight gain Works carbs may be our
body's preferred fuel for immediate
energy but that doesn't mean that they
can't be converted to fat in fact if you
really want to get down to the
nitty-gritty you could maybe argue that
foods that increase insulin or promote
insulin resistance May preferentially
promote fat storage and if that's what
wak gain actually came down to then
carbs might actually be the bigger
culprit particularly low fiber high
sugar carbs like bananas grapes
watermelon Etc but as I discussed in my
video on insulin right here the truth is
all of those details kind of come out in
the wash so ultimately it really doesn't
matter what the energy source is if you
have more calories AKA energy then what
you need that substrate is going to be
stored as fat carbs too how much of your
diet should be carbohydrates what should
be protein and what should be fat what
percentage should all of this be so I
like to stick to 80% of My overall
calories coming from clean carbohydrates
10% from fat and 10% from protein and
the beautiful thing is is that when
you're eating the right Foods you're
going to naturally fall into this
macronutrient ratio without even trying
you don't have to count your Macros you
don't have to stress out and put
everything into my fitness pal no none
of that that's why this lifestyle is so
free because as long as you're eating
the right Foods you're naturally going
to fall into that AG 101 macronutrient
ratio without even having to try
probably not I mean assuming that
calories are appropriate North Americans
pretty consistently consume about 15% of
their calories from protein there's
actually a really interesting concept
called the protein leverage hypothesis
that suggests that protein intake is
more strongly regulated in the body than
the intake of carbohydrates and fats and
when we reduce our protein intake below
15% we compensate by increasing our
calories until we reach that 50 15% so
if you're not also carefully controlling
calories and you're just going Hog Wild
on all the fruit there is a pretty good
chance you are not going to end up in a
calorie deficit now I could have easily
been off on my calculations above seeing
as I don't know what she puts in her
soup but what I calculated was even more
extreme than what she recommends here
and what she recommends is pretty bad
especially for weight loss I talked
about optimal macros for weight loss in
my video right here but fat loss
increases is fourfold when we go from 10
to 15% of our calories from protein to
20 to 30% but even if fat loss is not
the goal this is not even enough for
like Baseline bare minimum Health the
lowest of the low recommendations for
protein is8 to 1 gam per kilogram of
body weight and that is like bottom of
the barrel basic that is not if we are
trying to lose weight or build muscle so
for 120 lb person that is just 43 to 54
g of protein per day that is relased so
little in my professional opinion and
yet this diet doesn't even provide that
poor protein intake can result in muscle
wasting reduced energy digestibility and
fatty liver and these effects can
persist well beyond quitting the diet
ditto for low fat we know that fat
intakes below 20% can result in hormone
disregulation so basically low
testosterone in men and low estrogen in
women which obviously can affect fertil
you know I keep thinking that debunking
content like this is like Captain
Obvious like no Sherlock it is not a
good idea to eat 4 pound of watermelon
every single day but then I see comments
like this and I'm like I have so much
empathy for the vulnerable individuals
who are following this and well of
course there will always be folks on the
fringes who will thrive on a diet like
this but it is a pretty slippery slope
for like everyone else so bottom line
folks fruit is amazing fruit is
nutritious I love fruit but a girl
cannot thrive on fruit alone even if you
throw in some potatoes so if you were
looking for specific details on the
optimal macro splits for your specific
goals definitely check out my video
right here and on that note that's all
that I have for you guys today if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up I would love to hear your comments
below keep it kind we do want to be
respectful here and I will see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye come on Poppy
oh she did
[Music]
girl